good morning believe nation today's
message is keep up the quality over to
you Hugh Grant TV go you shared the
prize of the venice film festival with
James trilby will be will be for that so
that for that performance yes and that
was wasn't that the up to the next level
after that for you yes and then very
quickly down from that letter what
happened well I was a bit of a slag and
just accepted everything that came along
I including some quite dodgy miniseries
and things like that and I hadn't learnt
the lesson that if you if you've got a
reputation for a second of doing quality
stuff you've got to keep the quality up
and side up the quality sink and I need
to have another boost to it you know
with four weddings to make everything
pick up again I love this message
because as entrepreneurs we're always
looking for opportunities we are
opportunity secrets it's what we do it's
social entrepreneurs look for
opportunities we see something wrong in
some industry and we're like I could fix
that that should be better and that's
why you started your business or about
to start your business or have had some
success in your business is because you
saw something that you wanted to make
better and you went out and did it the
danger as you continue to build your
company is to get distracted what
happens to a lot of entrepreneurs is to
get distracted they start down one path
and then they have maybe a little bit of
success and then they see like 10 other
offshoots that they can go off and do
and then you start doing all of them and
nothing gets done everything is in a
really mediocre way and your to-do list
just keeps piling up I'm sure we all
have a file somewhere and Evernote or in
a notebook or something email of all our
ideas and it just keeps growing right I
have a ton of ideas and people often
lose focus and you'll see it quite often
we you'll have an entrepreneur have a
big hit with their first product or
whatever the first part is that makes it
maybe it's not quite the first product
but you know iteration iteration
you spend so much love and effort on
making that first album and then the
second album fall short the second album
falls short because you're rushing it
you try to get the momentum you're
trying to put something out while it's
hot you're trying to rush into the next
market and it's not as good as the first
one because you didn't spend as much
love effort time energy on it and so you
have to make sure that everything that
you create everything that has your name
on it should have your stamp of approval
should be something that you are
insanely proud that you create it should
be something that you want to show to
your grandkids that you want to go and
show to your mom and say look what I did
if it doesn't meet that standard then go
back and make it better improve it and
so I think too many people rush on to
more opportunities and more
opportunities and more opportunities and
never actually get that next thing done
because they're not staying focused if
you have a vision if you have a plan if
you have a dream you need to stay
focused yes you have these tangents that
you might go off on and you may need a
team to help you kind of build some of
those out but stay focused on the
mission create products that you're
proud of and keep the quality level up
so the question today today is I'm
curious what have you done that you
didn't really release to its full level
that you weren't really super proud of
that you tried to put out just to keep
momentum going what story do you have to
share around that leave in the comments
below I'm gonna join the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day I believe in you I hope
you continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love guys
I'll see you soon
on expresso keep me go